I'm ready to go is luuka a fake
poly safe to say
exposed exposed
exposed when it comes to YouTube and
when it comes to producing videos in
general what you can do is that you
can show amazing language skills without
necessarily having amaz amazing language
skills you can cut you can edit you can
rehearse you can prepare etc etc so it's
an excellent point it's a fair point
that the world of language learning is
not always a happy place sometimes
people leave nasty hurtful and
derogatory comments today we take a
closer look at some of these comments
directed at one fellow the polyglot
Legend known as Luca lamparello Luca
thank you for joining us today uh so
dramatic such a dramatic introduction oh
my God what's going to happen in this
video I'm kidding yes well unfortunately
these comments are quite dramatic and
therefore I need to do them Justice
because some people are not happy with
you Luka and we need to see why fair
enough fair enough that's right folks a
lot of people have a lot of comments a
lot of critiques about many polyglots
including Luca himself and so today
we're going to look at some of the
comments direct at Luca his language
skills and even his methods Luca are you
ready to
begin I'm ready to go is Luca a fake
poly
kidding good question good question all
right very first question here is
referring to the BDT your bidirectional
translation method and also your way of
familiarizing slash memorizing
vocabulary the comment says wow your
method sounds like an absolute chore I
would bore myself to tears in a few
days okay well um I always say that the
birir finalization is a method that
requires attention uh people have when
people complain about poor retention I
think they have an attention problem so
that's the reason why the B or the B
transalation method is a method where
yes you do have to sit down and yes you
do have to spend 45 to 60 Minutes every
day paying attention to a lot of details
but that's the entire point of the birir
fation method and as I say there's a lot
of methods so if this person who left
this this comment uh just the mere idea
of using the B translation is a chore or
it's not something he would like to
spend his time on because he prefers
doing something else that that's that's
fantastic the world is big uh and
there's a lot of uh options out there
but uh you know I always believe that
there's um some good behind the nasty
always there's always a lesson to learn
so the lesson is yes uh what I've
learned from this comment or what I'm
thinking I'm learning from this comment
is that the birir translation can be a
chore um or can be boring for some
people and uh I think that's life and
it's it's life on the one hand and it's
my duty to show how and why it's so
efficient for those who want to give it
a try that's that would be my
answer thank you luuka we move on to the
next hard-hitting nasty comment about
you this person said in resp I'm scared
I'm scared I'm
scared hold on hold on for dear
life this person in response to one of
your videos about memorizing thousands
if not millions of words had this to say
this is so disappointing to see Luca is
a fantastic polyot but that doesn't mean
we have to follow his method
comprehensible input together with
extensive reading may be a better
alternative memorizing one million words
no thanks that sounds like the recipe
for clinical
depression I I love the conclusion I do
agree that learning one million words
can be perity for U you know clinical
depression um I don't remember exactly
where this uh where this comment was
probably in a video where I was talking
about how I've learned a bunch of words
and uh my answer and and my answer is I
kind of remember this this comment I
don't know if I replied I don't think so
but um the bottom line is that um at the
end of the day it doesn't matter how
many languages uh one learns what
matters is the what you do with the
words you learn in other in other in
other words when you start learning a
language you learn a bunch of words of
course and maybe 50 maybe 100 the most
common words and then I think the most
important thing that you can do with
these words is you know do something
purposeful uh do something
meaningful so for example you have 100
words you can start combining them which
is what I'm doing right now with Turkish
having a lot of fun even if I know
barely 100 Words and then you can start
forming simple sentences to express um
some ideas or to express uh to to to
form some sentences and um the other
thing the other part of the comment that
I think is really interesting is that
extensive reading is great so the more
you read the better it is for you uh but
at the same time in order to get there
you have to at least let's say get a
grasp of how the language works that's
the reason why I normally use the B dire
translation and I don't really care that
much about memorizing words at the very
beginning I always say this this is
really important this is a really
important concept when it comes to
learning words especially at the
beginning our mental infrastructure is
so small that learning new words is not
that easy so to me the main task the
main purpose of the B Direction
translation and of what I do is actually
to understand the language rather than
memorize words and then after three six
months when my language infrastructure
so to speak gets bigger and bigger then
words get attached to it more easily
like flies flying in a room like my
spider web is getting bigger and the
Flies are more likely to stick to the
ever growing spider web and the third
thing I wanted to say third comment is
that everybody learns their own way
there are some Universal principles but
if one doesn't want to use the B
directional translation or use my
methods They Don't Care About Learning
one million words and I agree that leads
to clinical depression or anything else
then they have their own path that they
can choose and they have to figure out
the way for them to memorize and use
words for Meaningful communication or
for Meaningful consumption of whatever
material they are
they're consuming they're going through
so that's that that that's the lesson
I've learned from this comment let's see
what the lesson is from this comment in
response to a controversial video you
put about Anki the space repetition
software this person said quote this
free SRS software is inferior and
irrelevant luckily my patent and Method
the BDT is far superior check the link
down below you can get it now for the
low price of
€199 you talk about wasting learning
time well if time is money then money is
time how much time would I waste if I
bought into every language Channel's
patented learning method you slander a
piece of free software and then offer up
your own €199 article in the same breath
I applaud the bareface audacity if
nothing else nice plug mate PS fellow
commentators if you couldn't tell this
guy maybe has a conflict of interest I
would steer
clear very interesting very interesting
comment I would say fair enough uh
meaning that in the in the language
learning world in the world in general
everybody is um you know talking about
their own methods and they think that
their own methods is better etc etc I
when I when I created that video when I
when I published the video I I knew I
would get a lot of flack because when it
comes to talking about whether a method
is good or a method is not efficient Etc
there is always a lot of um
uh controversy or controversy I'm not
sure how do you pronounce it controversy
would it be correct controversy a cont
always get it wrong controversy uh when
it comes to but you're a polylock fake
polylock yes shame on me shame on me my
English is like
A2 so
um so um there's a lot of controversy
because uh again people tend to take it
personally I what I did was just stating
what I believe what what has been my
experience with an and the way I learn
languages and the universal principles
that are behind the method I I use but
at the same time again if a person likes
Anki as I said as I think if I remember
correctly I say at the end of the video
like if you like Ani use it you know if
you like an the main point for me the
main point was that whether you like an
or not that should come as the icing on
the cake he should never go to the
detriment of actually listening and and
and reading listening reading watching
so just getting a lot of input I know
that this sounds trivial to me now after
30 years of learning languages but the
most important thing the most
significant meaningful and uh important
um activity you can engage in when it
comes to language learning is consuming
content that you find interesting
comprehensible and challenging or
slightly challenging this is at the core
of my language learning strategy then
you know we can debate and discuss
whether Anki is good whether flashcards
are good or not Etc I gave my own
personal opinion and I completely
understand if someone points out hey
you're selling a course so you're you're
like slandering something and then
you're saying oh take a look at my
course that's better that's was not my
intention it's never been my intention
to put um people down or put other
products down that's not really my style
I'm just saying I don't like this
because of this reason and then uh you
know you can take in stride you can
think okay he's got a point or he
doesn't have a point in fact in the uh
under that video there's a lot of people
saying Luka I like what you said here
because my experience with an has been
exactly the same and other people are
like saying exactly the opposite who's
this guy to talk about an you don't
understand anything you've never tried
it um and uh you have no right to talk
about this and I say fair enough like
YouTube that that's the reason why I put
you you know YouTube videos there which
we upload YouTube videos it's just like
for us to take a look judge uh write
comment and uh as I said everything is
great okay Mr Smarty Pants well let's
see what you have to say to this next
comment
yes this next one is directed at a
language of yours and not one of your
European languages this user said and
this is the video in which you spoke 11
languages so this is about three years
old if four years old if I'm not
mistaken your Chinese is obviously fake
not natural or fluent at all reading off
a teleprompter wow so impressive
Rive well uh when it comes to when it
comes to Chinese he's probably right I
don't think that when I when I made that
video I was proud of making that video I
think it was a great video uh the it's
it it's not because of my language
skills it's because the ideas behind it
so the idea was to create a video where
I speak every every language in every
language I say something that is useful
it's not like look at me I can speak 11
languages that was not the point of the
video and when it comes to Chinese I
remember that like every time I make a
video whether it's multilingual or it's
in English or it's in Italian you're I'm
always very critical to myself I always
look back and say did I say things right
I could have said this better and I made
that mistake or that mistake Etc and I
do remember very well that the the two
languages I was a little bit Ah this
didn't come out that well um were ma
Hungarian and
tan Chinese and I thought yeah I could
have I could have I could have done a
better job especially that the Chinese
tones were not coming out very well but
the truth is I just told myself I'm not
going to redo this video and you know
why I thought this is my level of
Chinese now I do not speak it this well
because I haven't practiced it in like
when I made that video I think it was
2020 or something like that yeah 2020 I
think it been like it had been seven
years I hadn't so much as touched
anything when it comes to Chinese and I
still remember um by the way that when I
hosted uh I think in
2016 I hosted a um a Chinese girl I
wanted to speak with her so I hadn't
spoken Chinese or done anything when it
comes to Chinese for like four years and
I try to say something like uh um Let me
let me see if I remember this
now so I wanted to see I I hope this is
right I'm not 100% sure I work I used to
work as an engineer I wanted to work as
an engineer
like is
engineer sorry is to work and I cannot I
didn't remember for the life of me how
to say to work and and I thought gosh I
I was just like I I was kind of fluent
in Chinese because I was speaking it
every day with people like for example
when I started learning it back in
28 2008 I was so passionate about it and
I jumped on there was a site that
doesn't exist anymore I was speaking
every day with Chinese were going oh
like they were very surprised and then
all of a sudden four years down the path
I couldn't say like something like as as
basic as like I work and this is uh the
big lesson from this comment but the big
lesson in general is that especially
when it comes to speaking skills they
degrade very fast when you don't speak a
language no matter which language no
matter the level if you don't speak it
it just shrinks in your in your mind it
shrinks it's inevitable and at the same
time if you've been learning the more
languages you learn and the more likely
it is for other languages to be in the
back burner as they say right so my case
for example Chinese Japanese Swedish uh
Dutch Portuguese these are languages
that I barely speak and when I get to
speak them I'm very Rusty especially
when it comes to Chinese and uh first I
accept it and second the good news is
that especially when it comes to
Chinese I learn the language I got the I
I got a good understanding and a good
grasp of the language if I have to go
back to it it might take a couple of
weeks to go back to it might take a
month but I know how to get back to to
speaking it it's just a matter of time
and and decisions so fair enough my
Chinese sucked in that video and uh and
he pointed that out uh all the more
power to you
sir safe to say
exposed exposed
exposed take take that Chinese flag off
your YouTube
profile
as as a Chinese expert I have to say
that's right that's it all right this
next person doesn't just take aim at
your Chinese but rather your status as
as a polyglot referring to the fact that
all you polyglots talk about is how to
learn languages in X Y and Z languages
without going further than that and
talking about topics that you're
unfamiliar about so it says right here
I'll be much more convinced when I see
you speaking those Languages by having
an extensive conversation about ordinary
things with a native speaker of the
languages the reason for so many
contrary claims is because many of these
people are trying to sell you expletive
and their YouTube videos are basically
commercials they're searching for what
suckers what's the old saying there's a
sucker born every minute PT
Barnum love it lovely comment so I would
say this is a very um I would go so far
as to say that it's a fair criticism in
the sense that there's a lot of people
uh out there and I'm not naming anybody
not making any names but when it comes
to YouTube and when it comes to
producing videos and general what you
can do is that you
can show amazing language skills without
necessarily having amaz amazing language
skills you can cut you can edit you can
rehearse you can prepare etc etc so it's
an excellent point it's a fair point
that um you know in order to assess
whether a person can really speak a
foreign language you should first spend
time with them to see them like act and
and act and react live across a number
of uh a wide range of uh you know
circumstances and talking about multiple
topics that's how you actually can
assess and gauge one's uh level in a
foreign language that's the first thing
you can't get to see that on YouTube
it's difficult you should get to know
the person like and even if you saw a
couple of hours of a person like free
freely speaking you can you can tell
okay this guy speaks well or this guy
doesn't speak well but then again you
have to spend time
um with them in order to understand as
far as I'm concerned I H I do have some
videos where I speak for an extended
period of time in English French Spanish
I have it in Russian I have it in Polish
and I have it in other languages and I
should make more videos on that regard
um speaking like I'm speaking to you in
English with long form interviews Etc
it's just
that it's just that I haven't done it I
haven't produced many of those videos
out there but um you know the the thing
is I don't have to prove whether I can
actually speak these languages I do it
for my personal life I tend to have long
conversations in my personal life and I
can do that on YouTube it's not a
problem uh but to make a long story
short I understand why some people can
criticize me thinking that I belong to
that group of people who are fake
polyglots or like cut and edit and stuff
I can tell you with you know that I'm
not that in the sense that I learn
languages to live a better life so I
don't learn languages to impress people
on YouTube when I hopped on YouTube for
the first time I just wanted to
naturally like really I I was driven by
this um this desire of sharing what I
could do I still remember the first time
it was like the 22nd of May 2008 I just
said I gotta do this I gotta do this
just like I hopped on I just turned on
this really crappy camera Pard done my
French French and I just shot a video I
just filmed a video of me speaking to
languages it was the worst video I've
ever done not in terms of content but in
terms of quality but then people
appreciated that I was sharing that and
I never got criticized at the very
beginning for saying oh you just said a
couple of sentences in this language and
that language it's easy because people
were super enthusiastic about the fact
that I had made a video uh speaking
those languages and they maybe they
could tell they got a glimpse of oh this
guy is actually good speaking these
languages it was it exciting back in the
day so we moved from excitement back in
the day where you could not see a lot of
polyus around to um fears and harsh
criticism for um you know so many polys
being out there and everybody wanted to
share their products
Etc but my my suggestion my suggestion
for those who leave nasty comments is
like why are you leaving a nasty comment
right it's like you just watched a a
video for 20 minutes and then the only
thing you the only thing you leave is a
nasty comment what does that say about
your state of mind and your mindset
rather than you know the person uh that
you're the the person who made the video
that's that's a lesson for those who
leave a lot of nasty comments it's
because they have personal problems I
know this sounds harsh but that's the
way it is if if you had a super duper
life and you were like um satisfied with
what you have I do not think you would
be uh lurking on the internet lurking on
YouTube leaving nasty comments about
other people's work but that's my only
take that's it I think the comments will
be filled with the following phrases
fraud gaslighting victim
blamer oh boy LCA we we thank you for
this session of hard-hitting questions
and nasty comments with Luca and we look
forward to another one in the future
thank you peace and love to you all or
Riv or
Riv